continúa el avance de las tropas rusas
hacia kiev la capital de ucrania
mientras que en el sur del país de la
asediada ciudad portuaria de mariupol es
escenario de intensos combates el
presidente ucraniano llama a vladimir
putin al diálogo y el kremlin pide una
negociación más activa
según naciones unidas más de 35 millones
de personas han huido de la guerra en
ucrania y la situación de los refugiados
es preocupante los problemas de salud
mental y los peligros a los que se
enfrentan los niños que viajan sin sus
padres alertan el organismo
a 9 años de prisión fue condenado del
opositor ruso alexéi navalni por los
delitos de fraude y desacato acusado de
usar dinero de donaciones a su fundación
para fines personales el principal
detractor de vladimir putin cumple una
condena de dos años y medio por cargos
que él considera fabricados por el
kremlin
bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en france 24 yo soy daniel
hablando comenzamos hablando de la
guerra en ucrania a medida que continúa
el avance de las tropas rusas hacia kiev
a la capital en donde los residentes
están bajo toque de queda al menos hasta
el miércoles
explosiones y ráfagas de disparos se
escucharon en la ciudad y un humo negro
se elevó por el noroeste donde rusia ha
tratado de capturar varias áreas
suburbanas consideradas objetivos
cruciales para tomar el control del
centro y mientras la ofensiva rusa
continúa el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski pidió nuevamente a
vladimir putin un acercamiento directo y
desde el kremlin contestaron que los
diálogos avanzan pero con lentitud y de
manera menos sustancial a la deseada
en el sur de ucrania la atención sigue
puesta sobre la asediada ciudad de
mariupol escenario de intensos combates
y bombardeos incluso sobre edificios
residenciales escuelas y teatros donde
se refugiaban ciertos de personas las
fuerzas ucranianas se rehusaron el lunes
a aceptar un ultimátum ruso para deponer
las armas que dicen que hay unos 100
miles civiles atrapados en la ciudad
portuaria debido a la falta de
corredores seguros
una mariupol irreconocible desde la
distancia mientras moscú continúa su
intenso bombardeo sobre la ciudad
meridional asediada apuntando a
edificios civiles en un vídeo grabado
por la cadena de televisión rusa se
muestra a los civiles corriendo para
refugiarse bajo los disparos los
intensos combates callejeros se suceden
por toda la ciudad algunos cientos de
miles de personas aún permanecen allí en
la ciudad que ha sido asediada desde
hace tres semanas
esa era mi casa había un hermoso jardín
al frente mira lo que ha quedado es un
pequeño apocalipsis
en los últimos días algunos ciudadanos
han logrado escapar los corredores
humanitarios ayudaron a 30.000
residentes a evacuar hacia zamorilla
pero su vida no ha estado exenta de
tragedia en este hospital infantil una
niña está gravemente herida
esta niña va a perder su pierna está muy
traumatizada y no ha podido comer ni
beber durante días tenemos que
alimentarla a través de un goteo
intravenoso como mujeres buenos hijos mi
show en el pasillo del hospital un padre
yo era desesperado la muerte de su hija
de ministerio
corría hacia mi hija grité dominican
dominica
pero ella estaba tumbada inconsciente de
mi pequeña no pude protegerte
mientras continúan los bombardeos rusos
sobre la ciudad las autoridades
ucranianas insisten en que no se
rendirán el presidente volodymyr
selenski califica el ataque de moscú a
la ciudad como un terror que se
recordara durante siglos
el secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio guterres calificó la invasión
rusa de ucrania como una guerra absurda
y es que según este organismo ya son más
de 35 millones de refugiados los que ha
provocado el conflicto iniciado hace
casi un mes la onu advirtió que las
repercusiones de la guerra ya se están
sintiendo en todo el mundo y amenazan
con convertirse en una crisis global de
hambre
y
esta guerra no se puede ganar tarde o
temprano tendrá que pasar del campo de
batalla a la mesa de paz y eso es
inevitable la única pregunta es cuántas
vidas más deben perderse cuántas bombas
más deben caer cuántas mariupol se deben
ser destruidas
cuántos ucranianos y rusos más deben
morir antes de que todo el mundo se dé
cuenta de que esta guerra no tiene
ganadores sino sólo perdedores winners
aun ilusos
la continuación de la guerra en ucrania
es moralmente inaceptable políticamente
indefendible y militarmente up surf en
símbolo militar y lee jones en xico y
mientras miles de personas se desplazan
diariamente de sus hogares a nivel
interno se sigue se sigue agravando
también la crisis de refugiados según la
agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados más de 3,5 millones de
personas han huido de la guerra del
total de más de dos millones cruzaron la
frontera hacia polonia donde
representante local de la organización
mundial de la salud aseguró que medio
millón necesita apoyo para trastornos
mentales muchos de ellos con problemas
graves de salud mental
zenit shop te refugies las necesidades
de los refugiados son muchas
principalmente problemas de salud al
llegar de ucrania lo que estamos viendo
en los centros de recepción es fiebre
diarrea hipotermia infecciones del
tracto respiratorio superior paro
cardíaco angustia mental y emocional and
it's tres naciones unidad también alertó
sobre el creciente número de niños que
hacen este viaje solos y los peligros a
los que se enfrentan pues advierten que
pueden caer en redes de tráfico de
personas o incluso pederastia desde la
frontera polaca nuestra corresponsal
pilar cebrián con el informe
estamos en presentes este pueblo
fronterizo polaco que se ha convertido
en un cruce de caminos hacia donde
llegan todos esos ucranianos que
abandonan la guerra y es en este pueblo
a 20 kilómetros de la frontera donde
deciden hacia dónde dirigirse dónde cómo
continuar con su éxodo o bien asentarse
en otras ciudades de polonia o dirigirse
hacia otros países de la unión europea y
lo estamos viendo este es un éxodo
protagonizado por mujeres y niños sin
duda esta es la población más vulnerable
y eso ha llamado la atención
organizaciones humanitarias que han
puesto el foco sobre todo en esos niños
que están cruzando solos la frontera son
los menores no acompañados hoy unicef
nos ha dicho que en una semana en
contabilizado más de 500 aunque
probablemente sean muchos más y para
ello unicef está colocando carpas en los
puntos fronterizos con ucrania para
intentar vigilar e identificar a esos
niños que están entrando solos en
polonia para intentar ofrecerles
asistencia preguntarles si están con
otros familiares o con otros adultos y
si no es así se están cruzando solos
ponerlos a la custodia de estas
organizaciones internacionales y después
entregarlos a las autoridades de polonia
es un tema que preocupa mucho y que
además las organizaciones dicen que los
próximos días lo iremos viendo más más
niños huyendo solos de la guerra porque
o bien los padres van a morir en el
conflicto o también en este proceso de
la guerra vemos como las familias se
están dividiendo y es por eso que en los
próximos días veremos muchos niños
abandonando solo es la guerra de ucrania
y en rusia el líder opositor a alexei na
y fue condenado a nueve años de prisión
de máxima seguridad por un tribunal en
moscú un juez lo acusó de fraude de gran
escala y desacato en un juicio que sus
simpatizantes ven como un intento del
kremlin de mantenerlo por fuera de la
escena política el mayor tiempo posible
el más ferviente detractor de vladimir
putin quien se declaró inocente y cuyos
abogados fueron detenidos brevemente
después de la audiencia ya cumplía una
condena de dos años y medio en un campo
de prisioneros al este de moscú por
supuestas violaciones de libertad
condicional
agosto de 2020 alexéi navalni se enfermó
con un fuerte dolor de estómago en un
vuelo desde siberia la principal figura
de la oposición rusa fue sacado a toda
prisa del avión y posteriormente
trasladado entre la vida y la muerte a
berlín en alemania los médicos
encontraron en sus análisis rastros de
no [__] que una sustancia química
potencialmente letal un envenenamiento
que provocó indignación en todo el mundo
al escena bani se recuperó y siguió
desafiando al kremlin sin luz esa gente
ahora me guarda rencor porque no
pudieron matarme y yo sobreviví y ahora
me amenazan con meterme en la cárcel
durante años alexéi navalni ha estado en
el punto de mira del gobierno ruso este
abogado moscovita ha hecho de la lucha
contra la corrupción su caballo de
batalla fue en 2011 durante las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
siguieron a las elecciones legislativas
de ese mismo año cuando navalny adquirió
realmente notoriedad luego tuvo que
hacer malabares con varias condenas
suspendidas primero por malversación de
fondos que le impidieron presentarse a
las elecciones presidenciales de 2018 a
su regreso a rusia a principios de 2021
fue arrestado luego fue trasladado tras
un juicio rápido a una colonia penal por
haber violado el control judicial
durante su anterior condena
no son los dueños de nuestro país y
nunca lo serán y un gran número de
personas decenas de millones de personas
están de acuerdo conmigo
hoy alexéi navalni está cumpliendo una
condena de dos años y medio en prisión y
este martes fue sentenciado a nueve años
adicionales acusado de fraude y desacato
desde su celda no ha dudado en denunciar
la intervención rusa en ucrania y ha
llamado a los ciudadanos a protestar en
las calles contra la guerra cambiamos de
continente y venimos para américa en
eeuu avanza el segundo día de audiencia
de confirmación ante el congreso de que
tanja y brawn jackson quien fue
postulada por el presidente joe biden a
la corte suprema de justicia hablamos
previamente con nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vázquez quien nos
contó que le falta el proceso de
confirmación
yo bailé la nominó hace unas semanas el
proceso de confirmación empezó ayer con
testimonios iniciales hoy y mañana
tendrán será el período de preguntas 22
senadores del comité judicial del senado
tendrán 30 minutos cada uno para hacer
sus respectivas preguntas estas son
audiencias que durarán casi hasta 12
horas en las que quedan si brawn jackson
tendrá que responder a estos 22
senadores y ya el jueves será el turno
de testigos que conocen agitan chevron
jackson y que respaldan su trabajo el
presidente del comité judicial del
senado richard durbin dijo que quiere
confirmar a la juez a la primera
afroamericana en la corte suprema de
justicia antes del 8 de abril es decir
antes de el receso de pascua
y en el sur de francia una figura
destacada del movimiento nacionalista de
la región de córcega murió tras recibir
una fuerte paliza en un centro de
detención
iván el colonia cumplía cadena perpetua
por el asesinato en 1998 del máximo
responsable del gobierno francés en la
isla mediterránea a principios de este
mes fue agredido por un compañero de
prisión un incidente que desencadenó en
violentas protestas el mandatario
francés está considerando ofrecer más
autonomía para el territorio como un
intento para apaciguar las tensiones
un icono del movimiento nacionalista
corso y uno de los presos más famosos de
francia yvan colonna murió a los 61 años
había pasado las últimas tres semanas en
coma tras ser brutalmente golpeado y
estrangulado en el gimnasio de una
prisión del sur de francia su atacante
aún deja lista camerunés que cumplía
condena allí por cargos de terrorismo
al parecer enfadado por lo que llamo
declaraciones blasfemas de colom a el
propio colom a era un asesino convicto
declarado culpable del asesinato del
prefecto corso cloud jean jacques el 6
de febrero de 1998 digna que el máximo
responsable de la autoridad estatal
francesa en el territorio insular fue
asesinado a tiros en la capital regional
a casio los interrogatorios de los
militantes nacionalistas detenidos
centraron las sospechas en colon a que
reivindicó su inocencia en una
entrevista televisada
necesitan un chivo expiatorio y nosotros
podríamos encajar en el perfil de
alguien que fuera responsable de esta
acción pero no lo hicieron y furia antes
de que pudieran detenerlo huyó pasando
cuatro años escondido como pastor en las
escarpadas montañas cortas finalmente
fue detenido en julio de 2003 y en 2007
fue declarado culpable y condenado a
cadena perpetua su asalto el 2 de marzo
provocó protestas y disturbios en
córcega donde las simpatías por los
movimientos separatistas perduran a
pesar del fin oficial de la resistencia
armada en 2014 el gobierno francés ha
respondido con una oferta de mayor
autonomía para la región en un intento
por calmar los disturbios que han
estallado a pocas semanas de las
elecciones presidenciales francesas
y en israel al menos cuatro personas
murieron en la ciudad de bersheva en el
sur del país tras un ataque con cuchillo
el atacante también falleció tras
recibir un disparo de un transeúnte las
autoridades informaron que el
responsable de los hechos sería un árabe
con ciudadanía israelí a quien se le
vinculó con el autodenominado estado
islámico este es uno de los ataques más
mortíferos en israel en varios años
según informaron la policía y los
servicios de emergencia
y cerramos con información deportiva el
tenista rafael nadal estará fuera de las
canchas por entre 4 y 6 semanas después
de sufrir una fisura en una de sus
costillas el incidente que originó la
fractura ocurrió el pasado sábado en el
partido de semifinales del indian wells
en california contra su compatriota
carlos alcaraz la estrella del tenis
mundial no podrá atender el masters de
montecarlo el próximo mes y está en duda
su participación en los eventos atp 1000
en madrid y roma en mayo próximo
con esto nos despedimos quédense con
nosotros en france 24